Your database can easily find every user
between age 20 and 30 in milliseconds.
But when you ask it to find every driver
within 2 km of a rider for an Uber-like
app, it falls over. Now, on the surface,
these two queries look really similar,
but they're actually very different. The
age query is fast because a B-tree keeps
sorted keys packed together on disk. 20
sits next to 21, sits next to 22.
They're on the same page. So, everyone
between 20 and 30 is one seek and a
short read. Location doesn't work that
way. You have two numbers, latitude and
longitude. And what you care about is
the straight-line distance between two
points. Two B-trees don't save you here,
either. [clears throat] One on lat gives
you a horizontal strip of the earth. One
on long gives you a vertical strip of
the earth, and their intersection is
still millions of rows that you have to
check the distance between them and your
point of interest by hand. Now, the real
problem is that 1D sort order doesn't
preserve 2D closeness. Take two cabs
parked five blocks away in Midtown,
Manhattan. They're neighbors. But if
your 1D index sorts on longitude alone,
every other cab in the city at a
longitude between them, from Bronx down
to Staten Island, gets crammed into the
index between these two neighbors.
They're a block apart on the street, and
a millions of rows apart in your
database. Any naive flattening of 2D
into 1D rips apart the relationship we
actually care about. Now, every modern
production system, Postgres,
Elasticsearch, Redis, Google Maps, Uber,
they've all converged on one of two
approaches to solving this proximity
search problem. Either build a custom
tree like a B-tree, but specially tuned
for location, or turn latitude and
longitude into a single key that a plain
B-tree can already sort. Why is B-tree
the prize? Because it's the one data
structure databases have spent 50 years
tuning. It stays balanced as data
changes, it packs sorted keys into disk
pages, so range query is one seek and a
sweep, and every database you'd ever
reach for already ships one. If you can
squeeze your spatial problem into a
B-tree shape, you inherit all of that
for free. Now, this sounds more
complicated than it is. Both approaches
end up at the same prize, a balanced
tree of pages on disk that you can range
scan. Let's walk through how we get
there. The first serious attempt came in
1974 from Finkel and Bentley. They
called it the quadtree, and it's an
incredibly useful foundation to
understanding proximity search. Take
your whole map, split it into four
quadrants. If any quadrant has too many
points in it, split that one into four
again. They can keep doing this
recursively until every leaf has a
manageable number of points. To find
points near a location, you just descend
that tree one level at a time. At each
node, you compare the query point's
latitude and longitude against the
cell's midpoint, north or south, east or
west. That picks one of the four
children, and you recurse into it. You
then repeat this until you end on a
leaf. Then you check the neighboring
leaves, too, to catch anything that
happened to sit just on the boundary
from your query point. What's really
nice about this is that it adapts to
density. Manhattan ends up as a deep
tree because it's full of pins. A lake
upstate stays a single coarse cell
because nothing's there. We don't waste
so much of space indexing the ocean. But
this has a really bad downside on
latency at scale. Because these splits
always happen at the geometric midpoint
of a cell, not where the data actually
sits, a dense cluster like Manhattan
just keeps getting sliced in half over
and over and over again until those
points finally separate. You burn 10s or
more levels of depth in your tree before
you actually reach a leaf node. Whereas
a query in Vermont might have a depth of
just two. That means that your query
latency depends on where in the world
you're looking. You can't reason about
worst-case performance very well, and
the hot regions, the ones that you
actually care about, like Manhattan, are
the slowest. There's also a disk
problem. A quadtree is a pointer
structure, which means every node in the
tree lives at some arbitrary address in
memory with pointers linking to its four
children. That works beautifully when
the whole tree fits in RAM because
following pointers is a really cheap
memory lookup. But databases can't make
the assumption that the whole tree fits
in memory. They read data from disk in
fixed page sizes, and every pointer you
follow has a good chance of pointing you
at a page that you haven't loaded yet,
which forces random disk reads every
single time. A few hops in and you're
spending most of your query time waiting
on the disk instead of doing useful
work. Now, you still see quadtrees
today. Google Maps uses them for map
tile systems, game engines use them for
collision detection, but for a scale
database where the index has to live on
disk and stay efficient when it doesn't
fit in memory, we need something smart.
Well, 1 year later in 1975, the same
guy, he came back with a binary cousin
he called the KD-tree. The idea is that
instead of splitting all dimensions at
once into four quadrants, alternate. At
level zero, split on X. At level one,
split on Y. And back to X, back to Y.
You get the picture. One dimension per
level, cycling through. This gives you a
binary tree for multi-dimensional data
that's balanced importantly if you split
at the median. And it was the workhorse
for nearest neighbor type searches for
decades. But KD-trees, they have the
same disk problem as quadtrees. There's
pointers everywhere. There's no clean
mapping to pages. And so, great in
memory, but painful off of it. The
modern fix is what's called a BK-tree,
short for block KD-tree. Instead of one
point per node, points get packed into
blocks sized to a disk page. And the
whole tree is built once from a batch of
data. Elasticsearch actually uses this
for their geo fields today. So, when you
run a geo query in Elasticsearch, you're
hitting a 50-year-old algorithm with a
disk-friendly wrapper, which is pretty
cool. Next, in 1984, Antonin Guttman at
Berkeley, he came up with the first
spatial index designed specifically for
a database. Guttman had two problems
that quadtrees and KD-trees hadn't
handled. The first was shapes. Every
index before this one assumed your data
was a point, like a driver, or a pin, or
a user location. But real geographic
data has lines and polygons. A highway
is a line. A country is a polygon. A
Starbucks might be a point, but the
Starbucks delivery zone is a polygon.
And so you can't meaningfully drop a
country into a quadtree cell. The second
was the disk issue. Guttman wanted the
spatial analog of a B-tree. Balanced,
fast to read off of disk, fast to update
when drivers move, the pointer-heavy
in-memory structures weren't going to
cut it anymore. His answer was to use
minimum bounding rectangles. Every
single object gets wrapped in the
smallest rectangle that contains it,
with sides parallel to the latitude and
longitude axes on the map. A point is a
rectangle with zero width and height. A
highway gets a long thin rectangle
around it, and a country of course gets
a big rectangle that bounds it. Then
nearby rectangles can get grouped into
larger enclosing rectangles. Those group
into bigger ones, all the way up to the
root. The clever part of this is that
this tree stays balanced like a B-tree.
Every leaf lives at the same depth. So
every query touches the same predictable
number of pages from the database. Every
node fits into a disk page. Inserts and
deletions rebalance by splitting and
merging pages, just like a regular
B-tree does. There's one trade-off to
call out here. Unlike quadtree cells,
R-tree rectangles can overlap. So if
your query point lands inside two
bounding rectangles at once, you have to
descend both branches and check both
subtrees. So a bad insertion strategy
produces lots of overlap, which means a
lot of branches to follow, which tanks
performance. R-trees are the workhorse
of production spatial indexes. PostGIS,
SQLite, Oracle Spatial, they all use an
R-tree variant under the hood. Six years
after Guttman's paper, a team in Germany
published the R*-tree, which uses a
smarter insertion algorithm to minimize
those overlaps we were just talking
about. And that insertion heuristic is
what almost all of the modern R-tree
implementations are built on today.
Really quick, if you're preparing for
interviews, come join the hundreds of
thousands of candidates who use hello
interview.com every single month. We've
got tons of free content across all
interview types, like system design,
coding, behavioral, and even AI coding.
We also have premium breakdowns, videos,
and an interactive guided practice that
candidates love. Now, back to the video.
Okay, still with me? Let's take a quick
second to zoom back out. Everything
we've looked at so far, quad trees, KD
trees, R trees, they're all custom tree
structures. They work, but they're
complicated. Your database needs special
indexing codes, special query codes,
special tooling. What if instead we
skipped all of that? What if we could
take latitude and longitude and turn
them into a single number, just one
integer, where numerically close
integers meant geographically close
locations? If we had an integer, then we
could use a regular B-tree, that boring
thing our database already has, and
where range scans just work out of the
box. This is that second camp, and it's
the idea that took over most of the
industry. In 2008, a developer named
Gustavo Niemeyer took decades-old math
and turned it into something you can
actually compute in a few lines of code.
He called it a geohash. The idea is that
simple. Divide the world into a grid of
32 cells, and label each one with a
character. Your location falls into one
of them, and that's your first
character. Now, take that cell and
divide it into 32 smaller cells. Your
location again falls into one of those.
That's your second character. Keep
recursing as deep as you want. Each
additional character zooms in further to
the map. A five-character geohash, for
example, is about 5 km across. Nine
characters gets you all the way down to
5 m. The final string, something like
dr5ru,
is your 2D location encoded as a 1D key.
The payoff is that strings sharing a
prefix are usually near each other. And
here's the part that's really worth
pausing on. Each character picks one of
32 options, which is exactly five bits.
So, a geohash isn't really a string,
it's a stack of bits. The string dr5ru
is 25 of those bits grouped into five
letters for human readability. Read the
same 25 bits straight through as a
number and you've got an integer. Same
bits, same sort order. That's why Redis
can store geohash of 52-bit integers and
Postgres can store it as text and both
indexes behave exactly the same way. The
huge payoff here is that keys sharing a
prefix are usually near each other,
which means you can query proximity on
any sorted index in a database. Where
geohash like dr5 ru wildcard, that's
just a regular B-tree prefix scan. It's
totally efficient. This is how Redis geo
commands work in production. When you
call a geo add, Redis computes a 52-bit
geohash integer and stores it in a
sorted set, which is Redis's name for a
B-tree like structure that keeps entries
ordered by numerical score. A nearby
query is just a ZRANGEBYSCORE
against that sorted set. Basically, a
range scan over the geohash integers.
This is one of the most elegant uses of
an existing data structure that you'll
find in production. There is one catch
worth noting though. Geohashes have edge
cases at cell boundaries. Two points a
meter apart can actually end up landing
in completely different cells and
therefore get completely different
prefixes if they straddle a boundary.
Picture a rider standing right on the
edge of a cell, dr5ru. The closest
driver might be 10 m away in cell dr5rg.
A naive prefix scan over dr5ru would
miss them entirely. The standard fix is
what's called the 3 by 3 trick. You
compute the cell your query point then
walk to the eight neighboring cells and
query all nine as a unit. That way you
can't miss anyone within one cell's
distance of you, no matter how close to
a boundary you are. You can then post
filter the results by exact distance to
drop the corners that are technically in
your query window but actually too far
away. And almost every encoded key index
in production does some version of this
trick at query time. All right. Now,
geohash works great when we're mapping
out a city, but it starts to hurt when
you look at a globe. The problem is that
GeoHash treats latitude and longitude as
if they lived on a flat rectangle, and
the earth isn't flat. A degree of
longitude is about 111 km at the
equator, and nearly zero at the poles.
So, a cell that's one GeoHash character
wide is a fat square at the equator, and
a tiny sliver near each of the poles.
You want cells of roughly equal area
everywhere on earth, and you want a
one-D ordering that preserves locality
on a sphere object as a rectangle. So,
around 2011, Google built S2 to fix
this. The trick is to wrap the sphere in
a cube, and project the earth onto its
six flat surfaces. On each face, you can
subdivide cleanly into cells that stay
roughly the same size anywhere on the
globe. Every location ends up with a
64-bit integer called an S2 cell ID. And
like the GeoHash, the IDs are higher
arctical. Truncate the ID, and you get a
coarser parent cell. S2 is what powers
MongoDB's 2D sphere index. When your
geoquery correctly handles a polygon
that crosses the anti-meridian, that's
S2 under the hood. Flat earth indexes
treat such a polygon as stretching all
the way around the globe, but S2 knows
better. Okay, last one now. In 2008,
Uber open-sourced H3, which they use for
dispatch and surge pricing. The twist
with H3 is that it uses hexagons instead
of squares. Why? Well, a square has two
kinds of neighbors. Four sharing an
edge, but four sharing only a corner.
And the corner ones are further away.
That asymmetry makes heat maps and
everyone within N cells of me queries
messy. So, a hexagon has exactly six
neighbors, all at the exact same
distance from each other. And so, it's
clean math for the kind of analytics
that Uber runs every single day. H3
tiles the entire globe in hexagons, and
each hexagon roughly subdivides into
seven smaller hexagons. So, you can zoom
in as far as you need, just like with S2
and Geo Hashes. You get 16 resolutions
in total from continent-size cells down
to about a square meter. Every cell gets
a 64-bit integer ID, and again, like Geo
Hash and S2, the IDs are hierarchical.
Zero at the end of the ID and get a
parent cell. Now, you might be
wondering, how do you sort a hexagon in
the first place? And the honest answer
is that you don't sort the hexagons
themselves. You sort their IDs. So, H3
walks the hexagon grid in a
deterministic order, kind of like a
space-filling curve. And it assigns each
cell along that walk an integer that
gets larger as you move along the path.
Math aside, the result is the same
property Geo Hash and S2 give you.
Numerically close IDs are usually
geographically close to each other. So,
that a B-tree can scan over those IDs,
giving you a clump of nearby hexagons.
Now, the way that it works in production
is that every driver reports their
location, and the system converts that
latitude and longitude into an H3 cell,
say a 200-m cell. When a rider opens up
their app, you get their latitude and
longitude, find which cell they're in,
expand to the six neighbors around them,
look for any drivers. If you need a
wider net, expand to the cells around
those, and continue this until you find
the closest driver. Okay, let's start to
summarize what we learned. We threw a
lot at you there. Every production
spatial index falls into one of two
types. The tradeoffs between them are
pretty clear once you know what to look
for. The first type is those custom
spatial trees. The database ships a
purpose-built tree tuned to behave like
a B-tree on disk, where it's balanced,
page size known, predictable depths, but
it doesn't explicitly use a B-tree.
Postgres uses an R-tree variant. Elastic
Search uses that BKD tree. These really
shine when you care about shapes and
accuracy. An R-tree doesn't just index
points. It indexes lines, polygons, and
complex geometries, which means that you
can ask things like, does this highway
intersect this country? Or, which
delivery zone contains this address? And
you get an exact answer. The downside is
that your database has to ship a real
spatial extension. So, you can't do this
in a generic setup and writes are
expensive. R-tree inserts run a
rectangular packing heuristic to
minimize that overlap we talked about
earlier, and BKD trees are basically
write once since they're designed for
immutable segments. That makes them a
bad fit for data that changes a lot like
with Uber where you have many moving
drivers. The second type is the encoded
key. You basically turn latitude and
longitude into a single sortable integer
and drop it into a regular
run-of-the-mill B-tree and then you're
done. Redis uses GeoHash, MongoDB 2
sphere uses S2, and Uber uses H3. This
approach wins out on simplicity and
speed. It works in any database with a
B-tree or a sorted structure. There's no
spatial extension required. Writes are
dirt cheap because a driver moving
around is just a single integer update
on an index that the database has
already been tuned for. And that's
exactly why Uber can handle millions of
live location pings per second. The cell
IDs are also hierarchical, so you can
zoom out by just truncating the ID. The
trade-off is that you're mostly stuck
with points and you get boundary
artifacts where two locations a meter
apart can land on very different keys,
which means you usually have to query a
ring of neighbor cells and post filter
by exact location. Now, the rule of
thumb is pretty simple. If you need
shapes and exact geometry, reach for a
custom tree, but understand the
limitations on write throughput. If you
have points at scale with heavy writes,
reach for those encoded keys like
GeoHashes, S2, or H3. Thanks everybody
for watching. I really hope you enjoyed
this video today. If you want to learn
more about proximity search, database
indexing, or anything system design,
head over to hellointerview.com.